looking forward yeah we are looking
forward to learning astrobiology from
you as well heard a lot about you
i i will try my best to share with you
whatever
i have gathered over the years and i'm
also looking forward to learn from you
guys
yeah also delana is over here she has
done a project on astrobiology like
human radiation
traits and space
yeah hi dilara and i have also
watched her presentation on youtube
regarding the space radiation and how it
effects on mice it was really
interesting and also congratulations for
the publication thank you thank you so
much
so what are you doing presently
so i am currently pursuing my masters
and
um right now in my laboratory and in my
university as well
i will i'm live from my university's
place
oh god do you did you invited your
friends to join our it would be
interesting for them as well
yeah i shared it with my friends and one
of my friend is just sitting
right now beside me he will be listening
and watching it
along with me and i've also told my
colleagues that space manoa as well
about the event so let's see if they
have time they will
surely join that's wonderful
thank you for sharing with us we'll
begin the session in next two and three
minutes until other people join
thank you yeah sure
also today i will be talking about
literature review
so can i just have views from the lara
and video things you guys are presenting
any difficulties you encountered with
literature review
while doing your projects
yeah well that's a really intriguing
topic to talk about and
i'm also looking forward to learn
various ways to do literature review in
an efficient way you know
literature review is so crucial to form
the hypothesis but
oftentimes it just takes up too much
time and
we really don't know which one to fish
out well so it i'm
really looking forward to gain some
insights on how to do it
effectively and efficiently from you
yes i'm looking forward to share with
you as well what about you delara
any particular experience you wish to
share with us
well i don't know if i have any um
tactics or anything but
the more you do it i think the more you
understand how to scan papers
and i think it really just takes a lot
of practice especially
um with understanding if the
published article that you're looking
through is
has data that is um critiqued well
if it's peer-reviewed or if it's not so
i actually really look forward to your
presentation as well
because i'm you know interested in
making more literature reviews
so i hope to learn some things today as
well
correct we are also looking forward to
learn from you and we shall begin the
session now
a good evening to everyone from india
and good morning to everyone on the
other side of the
globe we are very pleased to have you
all over here for today's ceramics club
session
the theme for the session is
astrobiology
and we have two speakers who would be
representing astrobiology's theme
and would be justifying it also so first
we would start with subrajid barua who
is presently doing his master's in
molecular biology and technology
at scamt institute saint peter's book
and has also been an ex-research fellow
of fine biotech he will be presenting on
research experiences career suggestions
and his projects he has done on
astrobiology
after subrajeet's presentation we would
have
dilara decans presenting her project
on radiation threat on humans in space
she's currently doing her bse in
molecular biology and genetics
from bahashi university turkey and after
these two presentations i myself would
be talking about how to conduct
a proper literature review for starting
your research projects
but before starting with the session i
would like to brief you all about what
cyanics club is
what do we do and who are we so cyanx is
a bioinformatics and data science
student club
and it is an initiative taken by the
students associated with fine biotech
one of the main goals of cyanomix club
is to help the student community
learn more about bioinformatics research
via group sessions easy to take courses
and debates and discussion
in depth not only this but we also
welcome students from all fields of
life sciences to come meet together and
learn from each other
we helped each other to grow and
understand in knowledge of
bioinformatics
this club aims to encourage young minds
to push their critical thinking limits
beyond the school and college curriculum
we are also there on telegram the link
is given over here
and also on linkedin if you are
interested in presenting your published
research work
or project you can email me with a
request at raja root 3
gmail.com i am retrieving currently
serving as the president of psionics
student club so what do we do
at every session of ceramics club so
psyonix club sessions are held every
week
on thursdays we have two to three
sessions in a month
where we have interactive zoom sessions
we have debates on certain crucial
health topics
and further on so what are our main
goals so the main goals of our mix logic
and ceramics club is to provide
training and bioinformatics enabling
independent research guided by mentors
and peer examples
we also help students to do their
research projects by the research
fellowship
program that we have which will be shown
to you all by the end of this webinar
not only this but we also develop a
growing community with shared passion
for data-driven research and
appreciation of science citizen science
we enable students clinicians and
faculties of all backgrounds
and student knowledges to develop novel
and independent research using latest
technologies
in life and data sciences
we also have certain topics that we
put a keen point on namely infectious
diseases neuroscience
precision oncology microbiology that is
consisting of microbes and microbiome
studies
plant science and further on our main
motto
is to help you guys to apply to learn
how to apply
big data in biology we also help
students to clear basic concepts of
bioinformatics
to gain specific insight on how to use
tools of bioinformatics in day-to-day
analytics
we also have brainstorming sessions that
helps
each group of students to enhance their
critical thinking abilities
and how to apply the knowledge of coding
and bioinformatics in day-to-day
research is also been
encouraged in this club
on our learn portal we have two free
courses for those who wish to learn more
about bioinformatics and basics of
bioinformatics
in-depth namely introduction to
bioinformatics and introduction to
genomics
these are self-learning introductory
course works related to bioinformatics
and data science
also we have group discussions in which
we do review report writing
based on self-success three courses that
i just showed you
we have certain scientific debates on
certain crucial bioinformatics topics
we have presentations on research papers
we have post-doc fellows and research
fellows presenting their published or
pre-published work
we also have discussions and exchange of
ideas for the project
development or project inculcation
so how to join the club the whatsapp
group link of the club is provided over
here
or either you can email me at the email
id provided over here
we do not have any age restrictions and
we welcome all the ages because i think
that knowledge has no boundaries
so i welcome you all to this session of
the dynamics club
i would wish to hand over the session to
subrajeet now
so within you can start sharing your
screen thank you very much
well thank you so much ruthvi that was
pretty amazing to look through the
presentation the
design of fine biotech after such a long
time
it's always kind of a nostalgic journey
for me
to look at everything and so i guess
we are ready to go and thank you so much
for this opportunity and providing me
this platform once again
to talk about this i know i don't know
what happened in the past few years but
this field has just got its golden era
you can see and
right now everybody every organization
every
department is talking about astrobiology
so before we move on to talk about
the fantastic and interesting aspects of
astrobiology and the research domains
that
is present let me introduce you to who
am i and
let's just give you a brief introduction
about me and my journey so far
so as ruth introduced me i am an
ex-research intern at
find biotech and let me tell you i was
the first
ever research intern of pine biotech
india
so just like you guys are doing i have
also gone through the courses
and i earned my certificates and stuff
and
the mentors are so much friendly to me
even today you can see we are very much
i'm in touch with ilya
and he was very kind enough to bend down
some very
nice and kind words for me and so
that's the environment that's the
community we shared at fine and
even today i am really very much in
touch with
almost all the mentors and it's pretty
awesome but
let me talk about what happened after
that after i completed my finds
internship and then what so i had this
dream of coming to
this beautiful city of saint petersburg
which is also known as the venice of the
north
and get enrolled in an
university which is known as iqbal
university it was stands for information
technology mechatronics and optics
and that's the logo so i wanted to be a
part of this university and study
molecular biology and biotechnology
but didn't really want to do it
straightforward
so i looked for a scholarship
opportunity which is known as the open
door scholarship
which is provided by the russian
governments and
i hustled and got the result of the
scholarship exam and scholarship project
and i ranked fourth globally
and also received 100 scholarship from
the government of russia and that led me
to a direct admission to my dream
university you can say
without any of the exam or entrance
examinations and yeah finally i'm
pushing my masters completely for free
so let's talk about my research
experience here
so there's the scammed laboratories
which stands for solutions of
chemistry advanced materials and
technologies that's a huge family you
can see
over here and currently i'm involved in
various projects involved in various
such groups trying to do something great
in the field of astrobiology
i would have loved to share the results
with you but you know they are
pretty much premature right now and not
really i'm authorized not really
authorized to share with them
right now but maybe in a future uh
cyanide session or maybe some other
sessions when they are
good to go good to be published i can
talk about them more but finally
i cannot forget space unova the company
where i am currently the head at the
department of astrobiology
and let me quickly share what's the
vision of space manoeuvre and why am i
devoting my time to space on over well
space nova is a company which
has the vision to enable literally
any space enthusiast to become a space
technologist
in any of the domain of space science
they want
and that's the kind of vision we all
share and
particularly being the head of the
department of astrobiology i
really want to understand the
perspectives of life
beyond the cosmic boundaries you know
let me give you an example
just like the nature of physics changed
once we took into consideration
the universal phenomenon like the dark
matter or the phenomenons of black hole
similarly it's my strong belief that
biology would also
see new heights will be explored in a
different way will
go beyond our expectations when we start
looking at
biology beyond the boundaries of earth
you know so that's a lot about me and
let's not talk about
me much and let's devote our attention
and time to this beautiful field called
astrobiology
let's not drift away from today's topic
so
you know this is a night sky and i'm
pretty much sure
you once in your life might have looked
up at the night sky
looked up at these twinkling stars and
growing planets and wondered if
you are the only one if earth is the
only place where life is possible
and you know with all the scientific
advancements that we have had over the
past
decades and so mars seems to be one
planet where life might be possible
right now or might have been possible in
the past we never know
that's our neighbor and so many missions
are planned to mars
but mars is not the only one we also
have other candidates for example
jupiter's moon europa maybe
life exists on europa but so far
over the years after studying and
searching so much the only planet which
we have discovered
to have life in this universe is a deer
pale blue dot or also known as a blue
marble
earth so the question which i get
asked almost everywhere everybody asks
me this this question that
why do we really study astrobiology why
are we so interested
to search for life beyond earth what's
the need
well the short and crisp answer to that
question would be we are natural
explorers you know that's the
human nature that's in our gene that's
in our dna
to explore to know but why the universe
what's so special about that
well let's take for example this
particular comet
you know or maybe let's take an example
of any star for example the sun
everything in this universe each and
every object
is made up of the same star stuff
and what do i mean by the term star
stuff well
have a look at this this is a pretty
familiar picture to you all right this
is the periodic table of elements
but it's color coded pretty differently
and if you focus on suppose hydrogen the
first element it's color coded in blue
or azure color and in the literature you
can find the term big bang fusion
so hydrogen originates when
it originated when there was a big bang
fusion let's take for example carbon
because
every life form is made up of carbon
right that's the most common element we
know so carbon is green and yellow
that shows exploding massive stars and
dying loma star
so if you look at oxygen if you look at
any other element
discovered so far we would see its
origin or its presence
in some of the other stellar event in
some or the other
cosmic phenomenon and therefore
we conclude that each and every object
in this universe is made up of
the same elements it's me whether it's
me
or it's you or it's a star or a black
hole
everything is made up of the same
element and therefore
we feel a strong connection between
each of us and we want to explore them
and know more about them
so have we ever tried to contact the
so-called
life beyond earth well to be honest yes
we
did try to contact them that's known as
the receiver message
it was something looking like this i
would explain what it means
and it was devised by the great
scientist frank drake in association
with carl sagan
and it was short towards the globular
star cluster
m13 with a huge data that's
one six seven nine bits of data twenty
five thousand light years away
now what does this message contain
what's the content of this particular
message
so if you look at the first
if you look at the first level here the
whites
it's the decimal system that we have the
numbers zero to nine
then comes the purple one the purple one
is the elements which form our nucleic
acid that is hydrogen
nitrogen oxygen phosphorus coming to the
green part this shows that different
nucleotides that we have
adenine guanine cytosine you know that
very well
then coming down it's a double helix
structure of our dna
this is a human structure that's pretty
easy to understand here the yellow
region shows the nine planets it was
nine back then but now unfortunately
pluto has been declared as a dwarf
planet and finally the
above radio tower which shot this signal
unfortunately this receiver radio
observatory was taken down a couple of
years ago due to malfunctioning
so we have tried to contact them the
so-called
them but have we ever received any reply
well to be honest they did but we really
don't know from where it came from
so we received a message from
the so-called sagittarius cluster or the
sagittarius constellation
which is pretty much visible in the
night sky and this is termed as the
famous
wow signal well what is it this is a
very sharp
and strong radio signal sharp and very
prominent than usual
so you can see the usual threshold it
was way beyond that
and the scientist jerry r a man was so
impressed by this particular see of
this particular peak in the graph that
he wrote wow beside the paper
and since then we call it the wow signal
we
really don't know whether it was an
alien civilization which
sent us this message but definitely it
was really
exciting and interesting to get so
talking about
life beyond earth do aliens really exist
that's
one of the most common question or most
common thought which comes to people's
mind
the answer is we don't know we have
never ever detected any alien life form
we have never ever contacted them but we
do have some imagery of aliens
mostly inspired by the movies you know
like this one
maybe they are blue in color uh owing to
the copper rich blood maybe just like
it's similar missing in the octopus
maybe aliens are green with three eyes
like this toy alien from
the toy story movie or maybe aliens
would be like
yoda and many people would agree
who knows maybe alien might not be so
cute after all and they
are this ferocious beings with a hard
exoskeleton with a scorpion like tail
ready to pounce upon us and kill us the
moment they detect us
or maybe aliens possess says very high
supreme powers like the mad titan panels
from the avengers franchise
and maybe they are on a mission to
annihilate the 50 percent of earth's
population
the answer is we don't know and the
possibilities are endless but
i want to draw your focus to this
particular creature if you know what's
the name of this creature you can head
down to the
chat section and write it down but
i'm pretty much sure you would agree
this is very peculiar not
something which we see in our locality
this is known as the portuguese man of
war
and from here you would say that okay
this is a
creature with a tent this few ten
tackles that's common but
that's not the case these are not extend
tackles but these are
very small microbial animals living
together in a colony in a symbiotic
relationship
giving rise to the entire structure and
that's pretty
awkward or pretty unusual similarly have
a look at this creature this looks like
a giant cockroach right with
disgustingly large amounts of feet
and this is something which we don't see
in our home crawling that would be
disgusting
this is known as the deep sea giant
isopod and again this creature is so
unique
similarly have a look at this creature
what is this
well this is known as the axolotl and
what's so special or unique about
axolotl
well exotil the unique characteristic
feature of exotil is
they have reproductive properties or
they show sexual reproduction or
secondary sexual characteristics when
they are a larva
where when they are they are babies but
once they grow up once they become adult
they lose that property and that's known
as retrogressive metamorphosis
so you know there's so much about life
on earth itself that we
are not really aware of even after so
many years of research
so it begs us to ask the question what
is life do we really understand life now
if i ask you
what are those characteristic features
which defines life or which segregates
living
beings from non-living beings i'm pretty
much sure you would all
agree upon these particular points for
example responsiveness or consciousness
growth definitely living organisms grow
metabolism and energy transformation
definitely that's key to survival and
obviously reproduction without
reproduction
living beings are as good as non-living
things that's some people's ideologies
but you know i came across certain
examples which begged me to question my
belief
let's take for example responsiveness
have a look at this picture
this particular thing which is moving
here is a nanoparticle and it's
responding to light with the stimulus of
light
so without any artificial help this is
showing responsiveness
on the contrary here's a plant what do
you think that will the plant
change you and slap you if you break one
flower or a
or a leaf well a plant never does that
exceptions included
so you know even though they usually
don't show responses
they are living beings and therefore
responsiveness is pretty ambiguous
let's take for example growth you must
have seen these balls right these are
known as hydrogel balls they have the
property to absorb water and
grow in size and that's again growth
grow in
growth in size and volume so again it's
growth is pretty much
ambiguous let's talk about metabolism
and energy transformation
you would agree that this is a pretty
important metabolic reaction that is
respiration the process of breaking down
glucose with the help of oxygen
releasing energy in the form of atp and
carbon dioxide and water as
byproducts but again on the down picture
you can see paper burning
and that's again the same reaction
that's carbohydrate
with the help of oxygen burning
releasing energy in the form of
light and heat giving out co2 and h2o as
by-product
and again that's a challenging question
to ask
finally let's talk about reproduction
well you are all familiar with this
particular picture
and copying one particular file from one
device to another
gives rise to an independent file
which has its independent identity but
it resembles its parent
that's pretty much what reproduction is
so you know
if we talk about these characteristics
they lead to more confusion and more
unclarity and therefore maybe we should
really think about
defining life in a better way and one of
my friend
suggested in one of the previous
lectures that if we combine all these
characteristics together and uh and
you know combine them and confine them
in a particular vessel which we call a
cell maybe then we can define
that this is something which we call as
living being maybe that's a correct
explanation
but we really need to understand life on
earth and then only we would be in a
position to understand life beyond earth
also the discovery of certain bacterial
species which
we known as extremophiles expanded the
knowledge of light expanded the range in
which we can expect life
so here's a quick activity we can do
think of three places where life can
never exist according to you three very
hostile regions
if you ask me well it would be volcanic
eruptions
high temperature thousands of degrees or
centigrade and so many poisonous gases
there's carbon monoxide and stuff so
life should not
exist here well similarly in a very
acidic
lake ph around one or even below that
and life should not
exist in a place which is so highly
acidic or maybe even alkaline
and the last place where according to me
i thought the light can never exist was
a vacuum of space
with so many harmful solar radiations
there's microgravity
there's low pressure no oxygen so pretty
hostile conditions for life
right well again my beliefs got a death
blow when i came across certain species
of bacterium for example the
streptomyces thermophilic
which can easily survive in volcanic
eruptions
then there's acid thio bacillus
thyoxidase which can also thrive in
highly acidic
ph and in space in the vacuum of space
completely exposed
was dinococcus radiourans the bacterium
species which would survive for
more than a year and that groundbreaking
experiment about the international space
station
completely changed the way we look at
life itself
talking about this particular experiment
about the international space station
it spanned between may 2015 and may 2018
it was
named the tan popo mission and it was
designed by jaxa the japanese
aeronautical company and you know in the
japanese section of the international
space station which is known as kibo
they
exposed that of course radio endurance
without any artificial support
and they found that they could survive
pretty easily
for more than one year it's not that
there was no change noticed definitely
there was an ex
exo layer that was formed similar to
something like an endospore stuff
which died and dried off but the
interior was surviving
and also scientists discovered that
dinofocus radio urants could survive so
well because of its
highly fast and efficient dna repair
mechanism
and that is pretty amazing to study
further because if we can devise
something and utilize that property
maybe we can realize the dream of long
duration space flights without getting
harmed someday
the tanpopo mission also had another
objective that was
capturing the dust flybys at the highest
level of the low earth orbit that is 400
kilometers from the earth's surface
so these are ultra low density silica
gels or aero gels
and they are very porous so they were
also exposed in the hope of capturing
maybe you know light forms microbes or
maybe
some sort of amino acids and now they
have been brought back to earth and
research is going on with the help of
pcr and so many other
mechanisms and who knows fingers crossed
and we might find something
interesting in the future talking about
extremophiles there was a case study
done
in brazil in the sao paulo and south
pedro archipelagos
and you can see here in the list there
were so many different types of
extremophiles there that were found
there was hypothermophile thermophile
psychophiles
acetophiles and the list just goes on
and on you can
see that they can survive at
staggeringly high temperatures or maybe
very high radiation exposures can also
not affect them and
these extremophiles known as the poly
extremophiles forms the basis of
astrobiological research nowadays
and many people are interested in
studying their genome doing some
comparative genomics and stuff to
understand
them better where we can find these
extremophiles where here's some examples
this is a cave
in northeastern brazil then there's a
very dry region where we can find some
zero files
also in the antarctic regions we can
find underneath the snow
regions we can find some extremophiles
but
we might talk about them later on some
other day because
really time is constrained here and we
have to cover a lot
so with all these examples something
which is very clear
is we really don't know much about the
life forms on earth
and just like the saying goes that
charity begins at home
i believe that astrobiology also begins
on earth and is the best
place to do research and to know about
life so that we can be ready to identify
life somewhere beyond earth
now what is astrobiology well it's a
very multi-disciplinary subject very
multidisciplinary field of science which
incorporates under its umbrella a large
number of fields of science
but if i categorize them into very
broad aspects there would be origin of
life studying
the ancient life forms in the prebiotic
atmospheres
their search for life beyond earth
definitely which i was talking about
and to do that we also need geology and
the study of the environment
and finally we have space health just
like my fellow presenter dilora will be
presenting her research today and that's
on radiation
that's a an aspect of this particular
domain of astrobiology that's space
health how to take care
the health of human beings and shield
them from the cosmic homes
one of the other aspect of astrobiology
is a study of microgravity you know
microgravity conditions open
so many new dimensions to our
understanding completely
you must have seen such pictures of
astronauts floating around
in microgravity conditions but very
interesting things also happen
under microgravity conditions for
example have a look at this water
droplet
you would never see a perfectly round
water droplet on earth and that's
because of gravity 9.8 meter per second
square
the acceleration due to gravity but when
somebody is in the microgravity
conditions
the gravity ceases to exist or at least
ceases to dominate and then forces like
surface tension can take over and
similar things also happens with all the
fluids in our body be it blood or lymph
and they start
flowing upwards against the gravity and
that poses a lot of challenges
to whoever does a space travel so
it's really important to study all those
phenomena and all those
characteristics although space flights
are so interesting many people dream of
becoming an astronaut there are a lot of
challenges faced by them
to list a few well definitely
microgravity is a big challenge which
they have to cope up with and adjust
radiation is a big problem and again the
lara has
taken the first step to analyze those
and their effects
similarly there's low oxygen and
pressure that leads to stress and when
somebody is stressed when the body is
stressed so many
different mechanisms go on and it can be
noticed i will be talking about them
in just a while there's extremely
fluctuating temperatures as well
and a big problem to space flights is
definitely bone and muscle density loss
that's a reason why astronauts
need to exercise at least four hours
daily but that's not enough as well
that's a huge amount of osteoporosis
which is detected in those astronauts
and we need to do something to
counterfeit that and to enable these
space missions to be more
smooth we're talking about the research
which can be done
under this microgravity condition which
is a very very interesting
aspect and domain one thing which pretty
much
coincides with fine biotechs ideologies
and biotics domain is a genomic
response to study the differential gene
expressions and similar something was
done
in association with nasa the astronauts
whole blood transcriptome was analyzed
before
they left earth and after they returned
after their mission
and surprisingly it was found that 234
stress-related genes were differentially
regulated
some were upregulated somewhere down
regulated some completely stopped
their expression and that's such a big
challenge you would agree because
as many as 234 stress-related genes
going berserk in a human body would
definitely lead to certain physiological
uh phenomena and characteristics leading
to certain diseases
and that's pretty much an area where we
need to focus and do more research
talking about diseases in space well you
must have heard about cancer right
cancer is such a big challenge to
anybody who travels
to space but it's not so sorrowful
and not so depressing news after all
because fighting cancer from space is a
very new domain
let me brief you what happened in this
particular research
these cancer cell lines were cultured on
earth under stimulated microgravity and
also under real microgravity about the
international space station
and it was noticed then once
microgravity kicks in
these cell lines lose their potential to
get
adhered to the surface of the flows and
they start
floating and revolving and once they do
so they form multicellular spheroids
and these multicellular spheroids lose
their property of
getting attached to one another and that
leads to the loss of cell signal fungus
then signaling
and the property of cell signaling and
you know
that completely blocks the process of
metastasis
you guys who are studying cancer would
definitely know that metastasis
is an important stage of cancer where it
just becomes worst from worse and you
know this
study already gave that breakthrough
that metastasis stops when
microgravity kicks in and that would be
something very interesting to study
about
and to know more to understand the cell
signaling process as
well so that we can devise something we
can understand something which would
lead to our
successful treatment of cancer in the
future you must be remembering about the
example of bone density and muscle
density loss that i was talking about
a recent experiment what they did was in
a recent experiment was they genetically
engineered certain mice
and they knocked down the expression of
myostatin and actin
active in a coding gene and they found
that after
these mice which lack the these
particular
coding genes they become very much
sturdier their muscle and their bones
grow at a tremendously high rate that
cell signaling processing is completely
shut down so there's no limitation and
therefore the muscle density and bone
density loss is brought to
a very low a very
rock bottom minimal you can say so that
is another area another interesting
domain to look into to study
more so that we can understand how this
is happening and if we can replicate
them in humans and maybe who knows in
the future just like these mighty mice
we would send mighty astronauts
onto the space station and even to mars
who would not suffer from the problem of
bone and muscle density loss there was
another experiment which
took this in association with merck and
nasa and this is a monoclonal antibody
known as k
through them that's again a cancer
that's a
treatment for cancer and what the
scientists saw was they could form
pretty much homogeneously and uniformly
under microgravity conditions which they
could
not do in the control sample on earth
because of gravity you can see such a
chaotic picture here but here it's all
well organized and homogeneous
that led to the better characterization
of these monoclonal antibodies which are
highly efficient
highly selective and targeting is almost
100 percent
so again you as you can see these
research open new domain into this sort
of small molecule drug
and biologics ex research and stuff
finally let's talk about the recent
launch from spacex which took place on
june 3rd
and they sent two passengers along with
them that was the tardigrades or the
water bears and baby squids
the purpose of sending tardigrades to
space was to analyze
how they are so rated how they are not
degraded by
microgravity conditions or harmful
cosmic
radiations and to study that what are
the genomic processes what's the
what's happening at the genomic level
that's giving them such
a great strength the purpose of sending
baby sweats well baby squids are the
model organisms for studying symbiotic
relationships
and that's the sole purpose to
understand those symbiotic relationships
which they
do once they go to space and that can
lead new horizons you know we
human beings are also in a symbiotic
relationship with so many microbes
talking about our gut microbiome
and it's pretty much important to
understand the relationship between
those symbiosis and how it
microgravity can alter or affect them
so it's pretty much good to say that
space is a new lab
and talking about where the lab is
located well definitely the
international space station is one of
them
we are also coming up with axiom which
is going to be the world's first
commercial
space station russia is also going to
launch their own space station by the
year 2025
and good news for my indian fellows
india is also going to launch their own
space station and all of these space
station will have dedicated microgravity
research going
on board them now finally let me quickly
talk about the carrier opportunities
because that was one of the agendas and
let me tell that at the very beginning
it doesn't matter from which background
you belong you can still be an
astrobiologist
you necessarily don't need to be no
don't need to be
a biologist to become an astrobiologist
you can be an archaeologist and study
the
history of earth when the dinosaurs were
extinct when the oldest microbial fossil
was found
the formation of earth and also so and
you know you can be a biologist just
like me and most of you are biologists
study the cell the cell organelles study
the nucleus the cellular processes going
inside the center dogma of life
and study the nucleotides their
chemistries
and how they interact maybe you could be
a microbiologist and study tardigrades
and their phenomena
you can also be a geologist studying the
formation of studying these asteroids
well these asteroids are very
interesting you know
because they are like those grandmothers
who know a lot about our past
asteroid bennu is one of them and it
holds the secrets of the formation of
the universe itself
and therefore the osiris-rex mission was
planned and
now osiris-rex mission is bringing the
samples from the new to earth
and who knows what we are going to find
pretty much exciting
so as a geologist your purpose would be
to study the rocks the
history of earth and to analyze life's
evolution
you can also be an astrophysicist this
is the perseverance rover and its
partner ingenuity
which was a key rover sent to mars for
doing astrobiological researches
it landed on the jazeera crater but by
the jezebel crater because
the jesuit crater is the best evidence
of
a liquid ocean on mars you can clearly
find the delta the tributaries
carbonates and stuff that's a pretty
good hint that jesus crater was a lake
or a water body
and if it was a water body then
definitely life could be a possibility
in those particular
areas so in a nutshell you can be
anybody a physicist chemist
biotechnologist food technologist
architect engineer you can belong to any
background
and still become an astrobiologist the
only thing that you need to do
is believe in yourself just take that
first step believe that you can be an
astrobiologist you can contribute in
this particular field
and you're good to go one interesting
observation was that i
told that you can be a food technology
sort of foodie and still contribute to
testosterone biology
well that's pretty awkward but that's
the truth here you can see
uh an expert in food technology here you
can see people hired and what they are
known as
tasters and their sole purpose is to
taste the food
analyze them and decide what's the best
food to be sent to space for the
astronauts
so being foodie is no longer cliche you
can definitely
earn respect suitable jobs if you are a
foodie
so finally answering the big question
how to become an astrobiologist how can
i become what's the career path that i
should follow
so this is the carrier path which is
suggested by nas
and you can definitely follow this path
to become an astrobiologist right now
learn about astrobiology attend the
podcast boots
read books earn a degree in any of the
field that you like
you can do your graduate work you can
build a community just like we are doing
right now finance drinks based on over
is doing tests community building
learning together and then you earn your
phd and finally
you look for funding opportunities
become a postdoctoral fellow somewhere
and then you start doing your own
research in the field of astrobiology
and that's how
you can get a glorious career in
astrobiology that's what
nasa suggests and talking about where
you can know
more about these journeys well
definitely check out nasa astrobiology
program
as canastro biologist various
astrobiologists come and share their
life's experience in those
shows and that's an eye-opener for
anybody who wants to be
an astrobiologist in the future so
that's all i
had for this presentation today i do
hope that i did not take
uh much time here's the last
invitation for anybody who wants to be a
part of space
nova's community of global space
enthusiasts you can join our discord
server
and let us together stay tuned and
create a space ecosystem
where limit actually turns to infinity
well thank you so much for your patient
audience guys
it was really amazing for me to talk to
you and i am pretty much open for
answering a question feel free to ask
any question that you might have and
thank you so much for this opportunity
that was such an amazing presentation
literally and i think the audience would
have the same reaction
it was much interesting and we got to
know about astrobiology
so much in depth and it is much more
about
astrobiology than just space and biology
thank you so much for delivering this
wonderful talk
and thank you so much very thankful for
you to be over here
i may open this to the audience now
please put your questions in the chat
box thank you
thank you so much for thank you so much
guys also for attending
this session it's really fun to talk
about astrobiology
and so far we are all learning and
getting involved more and i hope that we
all can
contribute big time in the future when
we all are equipped with the necessary
weapon and arsenal that we really need
to contribute
and pretty much great to
yeah so i can see certain questions do
let them come in guys
ask your question and i would be happy
to answer any of the questions that you
might have
regarding this field of astrobiology
yeah so i can see a few um
questions so deepika advances in india
in astrobiology is pretty much happening
because
you know isro as i said has already
announced that it's going to launch
their own space station and also
recently they are
rolling out certain opportunities for
microgravity experiments and
astrobiological experiment to be taken
as a payload for one of their pslv
missions into low earth orbit
so that's pretty much an opening for
anybody who wants to do
from india and in the future definitely
we would be getting much more
opportunities till then happy building
your
knowledge also kashish have asked that
bioinformatics plays a big role in
biology of space and definitely you know
just as i gave an example
you can study the genomics of those
astronauts who are there
you can study these extremophiles and
understand how can they be so rigid and
so
much more different than the normal life
forms on earth what makes them so unique
and that's how bioinformatics would play
a big
role i feel and i'm pretty much sure
that in the coming years
many more domains would definitely open
this not
that this won't be stagnant for sure
thank you subragi if any more questions
you can please
answer in the chat box we are running
short of time
so can you please telara can you please
share your screen thank you subrajeet
sure
i hope you can see my screen clearly um
[Music]
thank you so for those who join
just joined i'll just reintroduce myself
and larry dicken and
i just recently graduated from bachelor
university
and i did my internship at uh pine
biotech in the omnics logic research
fellowship program
and my project was on the radio the
threat that radiation poses to humans in
space
and i will be i analyze the adverse
effects of specifically high
led radiation on the mouseket microbiome
and how this affects the nervous system
and causes psychological disorders
so i'll give a short introduction of how
bioinformatics is involved
and then i'll give an introduction to my
project specifically how i analyze my
data
and then i'll be sharing my results and
how i uh concluded this
and um i think that bioinformatics is
really
important because um during my time at
the wet lab i
realized that we're producing such great
amounts of data
that we need to process but the speed of
processing that data is not fast enough
and
by informatics and the machine learning
and other new technologies that are
involved
are a great way to speed this process up
and another thing that i'm fascinated by
and by informatics is that
the same raw data that is collected for
one project can
also be used for other researches as
well
and um so i i want to
shortly talk about my experience at pine
biotech
um and uh why i
joined it and it was because they have
courses for
everyone from beginner and then they
bring them
up to a more professional
level and that's why i had an amazing
experience
especially joined by my wet life
experience earlier
so it was like seeing the bigger picture
and um to start with my project
basically it was on the prospects of
space
travel and how the advancement of space
travel affects
the astro scientists in space and as
subragit was talking about in his
uh presentation a lot of different
fields
are involved in astrobiology and they
don't necessarily have to
be simply about looking for life and
space or
you know they don't have to be focused
on one thing or the other
and that's why i decided to focus my
project specifically on the health of
astro uh
astronauts and astro scientists
and um as you can see here on the
chart on the graph on the right the iss
which involves different countries and
different agencies
has started doing their projects in
numerous different fields including
biology and physical science
and um i decided to choose this
the health of astro scientists
specifically
because to be able to continue this
research out in space
we have to have healthy scientists out
there
and i also think that
the landing of perseverance and the
speed up of
our space travel goals as humanity
especially by with starting colonies out
in space
it's really important to focus on
research that affects the human health
so there are different types of
radiation out in space
um including ionizing and non-ionizing
radiation
and my focus was specifically on
ionizing radiation because it has
high energy and this can cause chemical
reactions
and i will frequently be talking about
something uh
known as high led radiation and this
stands for
linear energy transfer which is the
dosimetry it's a measure of the effect
radiation has on materials and
this is a very curious type of radiation
because
high led radiation can easily be
shielded for
larger structures but it can pass
through
microscopic structures such as cells
and uh as we know radiation can have
various effects from
you know major effects like cancer to
minor effects like attention loss
and as you can see here this is this was
taken from a report
from nasa and they were analyzing
how these listed issues
will be controlled or uncontrolled in
the next 10 years this is a 10-year plan
for the planetary mission
and as you can see at the bottom
radiation exposure to human health is
greatly uncontrolled
whereas above you can see other
things like bone fracture or reduced
aerobic capacity
and host microbi microorganism
interactions
and these are partially controlled or
we're hoping to control them by 2028 but
what we need to understand is that the
radiation exposure affects all of the
above
disorders so another reason why it's
extremely important is because as you
can see on the right
the six months on iss
on average the radiation exposure is 10
times as much as the
abdominal ct scan so it is extremely
important to consider
radiation in our studies so
for my methodology i separated it into
three different steps major steps and
this was data exploration
statistical analysis and my conclusions
so for the data exploration first i
found a data set from ncbi which
contained um 80 samples from the
mousekit microbiome and these
these atvc samples were separated into
two categories and basically this was
based on radiation and days
so there was 0.1.25 and 1gy radiation
and the samples were collected 10 and 30
days post radiation
and then using the um the
t bioinfo platform i use the data 2
pipeline and the phyloseq pipeline
to find the abundances and also produce
graphs include including the pca nmds
and shannon index which i will be
talking about
in detail and uh to ensure that my
observations from these
outcomes were correct i conducted some
statistical analysis
including anova and t-tests and as for
the drawing conclusions part
i was particularly focusing on lower
doses since they penetrate cells more
easily and i wanted to see if
the days also play a role because it's
important in the acclimatization of
bacteria
and also because these bacteria can be
targeted for therapy for different
diseases here we can see an nmds graph
which is
stands for a non-metric
multi-dimensional scaling graph and
here as you can see my focus was on days
because i saw a better separation
between
10 and 30 days post radiation and
as you can see for yourself as well the
10 is
circles and 30 is triangles and um
the 30 days post radiation was more
spread out throughout the graph
here we see a shannon index graph and
this involves the biodiversity
of the samples and it measures the
richness and evenness of the species in
the sample which is equivalent to the
effective number of species
so here as you can see uh when the
comparison
is made between all four doses of
radiation
lower doses which is 0.1 and 0.25 gui
radiation
the biodiversity decreases in the
samples
um and then i
this was another uh graph output from
the phyloseq
pipeline and for here we can see several
different things
at once including how the doses and days
affect the abundance
and these otus which are operational
taxonomic units
which will be equivalent to the species
as you will see later on
and how these are related to each other
and one thing that we can see is that
otu 4 and 5 are related
and we can also see that for
compared to zero gui radiation point one
and point two five
uh at ten days shows lower
uh the lower abundances of bacteria
so i decided to focus on these and i
did a statistical analysis first i
started out with anova
which uh i used three doses
zero gy for my control and point one and
point two five gui
because um from the previous uh pilot
seek out pipelines
as you i told you the lower doses were
more significant so i decided to focus
on those
and then my outcome was that the
days did not have as much of a
significant effect
but the dosages did and between these
two variables there was no interactions
so i conducted a t test keeping the days
constant
and just analyzing uh the doses of
radiation
compared to my control group and i found
that these four
otus otu three and four which which are
related and five and eight which are
related as you can
see and and the heat map as well
these were the significant otus and
these
were um significantly lower at 0.1 gui
radiation uh when compared to 2.25
and um this was according to my
threshold that i set at 0.25
0.05 p value and
i wanted to also check the abundances
because it is important to see which
families and genus of species increase
and decrease and if these correlate to
my statistical analysis
here you can see that i compared those 0
and 0.1 gy
and um the er er lactobacillus by fido
ercipelatricacy
uh families decreased whereas the
vertical microbial
increased and when i conducted uh
profiling and align these results with
my t-test results
i found that um otu three
four five and eight as i mentioned
previously
were in the lactobacillus and
bifidobacterium family
and as you can see uh the four species
lactobacillus gaseri and john sonny and
bifida victim longiman castorius uh
respectively were the results of my
profiling
so why did i specifically um focus on
these
oh well that's because these four
species of bacteria have metabolized
that
affect the nervous system through the
gut brain axis
and they do this through the
enterodendritic and vagus nerves
which play which play an important role
in
transferring the stimulus from our gut
to our brains
and these four species were associated
with
associated with the production of gaba
which stands for gamma-aminobutyric acid
which is the chief
inhibitory neurotransmitter in the
central nervous system
and gaba is extremely important because
when it
produced in low levels it causes
depression and anxiety
because of the lack of because of lack
of inhibition
of the stimulus so there's constant
stimulus and
these bacteria have protein coding genes
called glutamines and glutamine
synthesis as you can see in this
gabaergic synapse
they are gs and gls
and uh they these are the same genes
that are in the gaba pathway of humans
so
we can assume that as the abundance of
bacteria
that have these protein coding genes
decrease
the amount of gaba in our nervous system
will
also decrease so we have two pathways
that we can take
uh from here and that is we can either
produ uh we can either supply the body
with exogenous kava
or we can produce we can give the
patients probiotics
but exogenous gaba in previous research
did not give the desired effect
so probiotics is
a more reasonable solution a more
effective solution in this case
so i can um conclude this and gather up
the findings of my research by saying
that
uh according to my initial hypothesis
lower doses of high led radiation has a
greater impact on the gut by
phytobacterium and
lactobacillus abundances especially at
0.1 gy
and the acclimatization period can be
deduced as 10 days
that's because at 30 days post radiation
the
when we analyze the samples we did not
see a significant difference uh on the
contrary the abundance levels were
slightly
increasing and this could
be a result of the length of exposure
because we did not expose these mice
to radiation uh for very long
and i think that this can be
further research we are using uh
combined effects of radiation and
microgravity
and also increasing the length of
exposure to see how it affects
um the nervous system and uh
the abundances of bacteria so we can
easily say that this was a precursor
study on how probiotics can be used as a
treatment in psychological diseases and
how
radiation affects the nervous system and
um yes
as for my limitations one of my
limitations was on taxonomic profiling
because
as you know in bacteria
there are sequences that are very
similar especially because for
profiling we use 16s regions of bacteria
and for the same genus they are very
similar
so it's difficult to pinpoint which
species of bacteria you're dealing with
and another one was that the optimizing
the parameters of the pipeline but this
helped me improve my approach to
technical problems
uh encoding and and dealing with
machine learning and its parameters also
another limitation
that was caused due to the collection of
samples in the wet lab was the
sample size and doses there were 10
samples
per category and if this sample size
increased we could have more accurate
results
and we should also have in between doses
in between our four categories of doses
and we also look forward to research
conducted on
humans and astronauts directly and
that's because
that's because as much as we can analyze
samples from mice we do not know how the
mechanism truly works in humans
so um there are some researches that
collect samples from astronauts but
since
the durations of that astronauts are out
in space is much longer
that that is another limitation for
those researches and
here is my references
and i'd like to thank everyone for
attending and listening and i would like
to thank everyone at pine biotech for
their help
and especially harpreet koher and
ilya brotzky because they were my
mentors
and they helped me a lot during this
research and thank you to rutwi for
initiating the cyomics
seminars because i think they're quite
helpful
so thank you so much jalara it was
uh really very nice to have you and
subrajeet with
us today and uh i may not be able to
take the questions which all of you
might have
we you can reach out dilara and
subrajeet we'll share their mail ids
with you and i would have to end this
session here
sorry because we have another session to
begin with
it was a shop at like three minutes
before
so i would now just end this meeting and
thank you so much dalaran shobridge
it was really very nice to hear to your
work
and great work both of you like i'm
really very impressed
it was nice to know about your work and
thank you so much everyone for joining
today
and astro biology seems to be a very
promising field
so all the we have some few research
fellows as well here
let's discuss on this too and uh get
working
thank you so much everyone